[Music]
Kim Kardashian is shutting down those
pesky rumors that she underwent surgery
just to fit into her dress at the Met
Gala in May
yikes it's been two months since the
reality star wore this waist cinching
Thierry McClair number which led some to
think that she had her ribs removed to
fit into the tiny look that's crazy now
in an interview with Wall Street Journal
magazine she is revealing the secret to
her small waist a mr. pearl corset worn
under the silicone and silk dress this
look is called the wet look
[Music]
and it's made out of silicone quote I
have never felt pain like that in my
life I'll have to show you pictures of
the aftermath when I took it off the
indentations on my back and my stomach I
can only like hafsat Kim previously
revealed that she had to learn how to
breathe in the dress before debuting it
at the event sharing this pic with mr.
pearl on Instagram four days after the
Met Gala quote seven months in the
making and fittings in Montreal Paris
and LA corset breathing lessons from
none other than mr. pearl it was worth
it all ahead of the gala Vogue shared
this behind-the-scenes look at Kim's
last fitting if I don't sit down for
dinner now you know why I'll be walking
around mingling talking but I cannot
hardly sit she revealed the first thing
she planned to do when she took the
dress off I have a delivery at 8:30 in
the morning of 2 dozen mini doughnuts my
favorite doughnuts ever are from New
York and I eat a dozen by myself but
they're literally like this thing
there's there many many many which is I
think the dozen probably equals like one
regular donut
[Music]